we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p here's an interesting little
question that came in I david this is
nikhil calling from Naperville Illinois
um I had a question during your last
live stream you said that you were
culturally Jewish but not religiously
Jewish I was wondering do you still do
you abide by the rules of eating kosher
or not funny no thank you right I don't
I never have abided by the rules of
kashrut as it's called and I currently
don't however I don't eat pork it has
nothing to do with religion however it
just has to do with my research and
understanding of not only the biological
reasons why eating pigs is not
particularly healthy and my love for
pigs which are as smart or smarter than
dogs very social animals blah blah blah
blah blah i've talked about it before so
it's been many many years since i've had
pork or pork products interesting i also
don't eat pigs and i also don't eat
kosher so i guess we're on the same page
with that one yeah as far as that goes
we're on the same page yeah but no I
nobody in my family keeps kosher or
anything like that I'm not part of a
religious family whatsoever on the bonus
show today Donald Trump may not last a
year according to the money that people
are betting I'm going to talk about some
of the betting sites that are wagering
on how long Donald Trump the last
president I have a story about shark
fins in Hong Kong and we are going to
talk about what I am now referring to as
the Patrick k Ford controversy that's
what I'm calling it after yesterday's
voicemail on the bonus show today we
will talk about the Patrick k Ford
controversy and if you've missed that
I'll tell you what it's all about that's
on the bonus show there's one way to get
access to the bonus show that's why
being a david pakman show member you can
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership you can pay the regular price
or you can also get a discount by using
the coupon code i voted 17 you will save
a bunch of money but you'll still get
one hundred percent of the member
benefits